hi there steve kaufman uh here i am
again in palm springs um my wife and i
bought a little house here
so that we can come here in the winter
we have to come down now to fix it up
um i want to talk about communication
communicating and language learning i
read somewhere that they think that
language the language ability in humans
was developed
so that humans could collaborate in the
hunt or whatever whatever it was that
primitive human beings did
the ability to communicate intelligently
uh in other words the language skill
gave them a tremendous advantage as a
species
and when we learn a language
communicating
is what it's all about we learn in order
to communicate and we learn by
communicating
now to me communicating includes
listening
when we're listening we're communicating
when we're reading we're communicating
when we're reading grammar rules we're
not communicating that's not to say that
we don't have to look at grammar rules
to try to remind ourselves
uh of how things work in the language
but the main way we learn is through
communicating and in my own case as you
know i put a lot of emphasis on on input
and i had an opportunity uh two nights
ago to spend an evening with a
delightful russian couple
who live in palo alto
and to me was almost like a reward for
the years that i've spent listening and
reading
in russian
and they invited me for a wonderful
russian meal and i'm going to post a
link
to the post that i made on facebook
about
uh showing a picture of the meal and
showing a picture of the couple
ayona and anatoly
and i'm also going to post a link
that aliona made linked to a post on
facebook that aliona made about my visit
because i was visiting with them
because particularly alyona is part of a
project called mulbabar which is a
russian
uh
project
whereby journalists including a very
famous russian journalist called dmitry
jakoblev
want to create a new media which takes
some of the tension and hype out of the
present
atmosphere of i would even say hate that
seems to be prevailing in russia
the
hate antagonism specifically between
russia and and ukraine but in a broader
sense and so i very much support this
initiative
and so uh but beyond that for me to
spend an evening talking in russian
eating russian food experiencing that
russian
atmosphere that i i so much enjoy was a
reward and and just a final note
communicating of course includes
speaking but it's not only speaking and
just out of curiosity i looked at my
statistics at link
and i have read about you know one oh
well over a million words in russian
according to my statistics at link so i
have read much more than that uh i think
i have listened
i mean every day just about i download
from echo must be two three or four
interviews each interview is 30 40
minutes long i'm sure i've listened to
six seven thousand hours of russian over
the last nine ten years
but how much have i spoken again mostly
i've spoken with our tutors at link we
keep those statistics i've spoken 150
hours
throw in another 10 or 15 hours where
i've met people like the other evening
and spoken so i have listened 50 times
more than i have spoken that's not
because i don't want to speak i just
haven't had the opportunity whereas
there's ample opportunity to listen and
read
listening and reading is communicating
it's a wonderful way to communicate it
prepares you for those great
opportunities when you can actually talk
and use the language and of course the
more you talk the better you get at
speaking but listening and reading is
also communicating
and that's
kind of the point i wanted to make
tonight and i'm gonna make another video
again on the subject of of communicating
and and and listening and what we should
listen to and what we should read to
make it meaningful so thanks very much
bye for now